como en el último vídeo quiero hacer un
par de ejemplos de calentamiento antes
de hacer un problema de aplicación en
este caso las ecuaciones son un poco más
simples aunque vamos a seguir los mismos
pasos para desarrollarlas o más bien
diríamos vamos seguir pasos
matemáticamente legítimos para llegar a
una solución válida
aquí tenemos 3 x x menos 1 es igual a 2
x x + 3
veamos que podemos hacer aquí lo primero
que me gustaría hacer y no hay una única
manera de hacer esto pero lo que yo voy
a hacer para empezar es distribuir el 3
aquí y el 2 acá así que 3 x x 1 es igual
a 3 x menos 3 tan solo distribuido el 3
y esto es igual distribuyendo el 2 a 2 x
+ 2 por 3 igual a 6 y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es agrupar las constantes de un
lado de la ecuación y agrupar las
variables del otro lado de la ecuación
así es que vamos a deshacernos de este
2x que está en el lado derecho de la
ecuación para esto voy a restar 2 x al
lado derecho y voy
una notación ligeramente distinta a la
que usado en los vídeos anteriores y
esto lo hago así pues tú te puedes topar
con distintas notaciones
así es que voy a restar 2x de este lado
de la ecuación pero si restó 2x de este
lado de la ecuación también tengo que
restar 2x de este otro lado de la
ecuación y cuando hago esto que obtengo
del lado izquierdo obtenemos 3x menos 2x
nos da x simplemente x menos 3 x 3 del
lado izquierdo y del lado derecho estos
dos x menos 2 x se cancelan era lo que
queríamos así es que nos queda tan solo
6 x menos 3 es igual a 6 logramos
eliminar el 2x del lado derecho al
restar 2 x a ambos lados de la ecuación
bien ahora vamos a deshacernos de este
menos 3 del lado izquierdo para eso
vamos a sumar 3 a ambos lados de la
ecuación sumamos 3 del lado izquierdo y
sumamos 3 del lado derecho esto lo
podemos ver como si estuviéramos sumando
a la ecuación original la ecuación 3
igual a 3 que es una identidad como la
ecuación menos 2 x igual a menos 2 x son
al final de cuentas distintas maneras de
ver el mismo proceso y que no resulta
ahora el lado izquierdo simplemente nos
queda x se cancela menos 3 y 3 nos queda
simplemente x y del lado derecho nos
queda 6 + 3 es igual a 9 y ya hemos
concluido ya tenemos la solución de la
ecuación a ver comprobemos la solución
tres por nueve menos uno esto es 3 por 8
y esto es lo mismo que 24 checamos ahora
el lado derecho tenemos que es 2 por 9
393 es 12 2 por 12 es igual a 24 24 es
igual a 24 ya hemos comprobado la
solución x igual a 9 siguiente problema
z sobre 16 es igual a 2 por 3 set a 1 y
todo eso
dividido entre 9 parece un problema
peliagudo pero empecemos multiplicando
ambos lados de la ecuación por 9
entonces multiplicando por 9 en el lado
izquierdo y multiplicando por 9 el lado
derecho que tenemos del lado izquierda
es 9 sobre 16 z y esto es igual esto
se cancelan y me queda tan solo 2 por 3
set a 1 vamos a realizar el producto del
lado derecho así es que el lado
izquierdo nos queda 9 sobre 16 z y
entonces distribuyendo el 2 sería 2 por
3 z es igual a 6 z + 2 por uno que es
igual a 2 voy ahora a pasar todos los
zetas del lado izquierdo para eso voy a
restar 6 z del lado izquierdo y el lado
derecho voy a restar 6 z del lado
izquierdo y esto es igual a menos 6 z
del lado derecho que tenemos del lado
izquierdo sería 9 sobre 16 767 9 sobre
16 menos 6 cuantos 6 en dieciseisavos a
ver hagámoslo por acá 6 es igual a que
dividido entre 16 6 por 10 66 por 6 36
esto es 96 96 sobre 16 así es que es
menos 96 sobre 16
todo eso multiplicado por z este menos 6
lo transformé en menos 96 sobre 16 y del
lado derecho nos resulta 6
67 se cancelan era lo que queríamos
hacer y nos queda tan solo 2 y esto de
aquí a que es igual lo voy a hacer en
naranja a ver tenemos 9 sobre 16 menos
96 sobre 16
la diferencia entre 96 y 9 es 87 y por
supuesto como el mayor es negativo
esto sería menos 87 así es que esto es
menos 87 sobre 16 z y esto es igual a 2
y ya casi terminamos tan solo tenemos
que multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por el recíproco de este
coeficiente así es que multiplicamos
ambos lados de la ecuación por 16 menos
16 sobre 87 también del lado derecho
menos 16 sobre 87 y del lado izquierdo
se cancelan estos términos 87 con 87 16
y 16 menos por menos me da más me queda
z el lado izquierdo del lado derecho me
quedan dos x menos 16 es menos 32 sobre
87 y ya hemos terminado no es una
respuesta muy bonita que digamos pero
como hemos dicho siempre hay muchísimos
caminos para llegar a la respuesta
quizá hubiera podido multiplicar la
ecuación primero por 16 oa la mejor
primero haber distribuido el 2 de
cualquier manera si haces bien las cosas
debes de llegar a la misma respuesta que
nosotros hemos obtenido bien ahora
hagamos un problema aplicación ya que
hemos hecho nuestro calentamiento muy
bien dice manuel y tamara están
discutiendo acerca de un truco de
números que oyeron tamara le pide a
andrés que piense un número supongamos
que x es el número que piensa andrés le
dice que piense un número lo multiplique
por cinco
así es que esto es lo que le está
pidiendo cámara cámara le está pidiendo
a andrés que 15 un número lo multiplique
por cinco dejarlo haciendo multiplique
por cinco así es que lo multiplica por
cinco y resta tres del resultado y reste
déjame hacerlo con un color distinto lo
voy a hacer en azul y reste tres del
resultado
así es que reste tres del resultado
entonces es el turno de manuel aquí está
a manuel así es que manuel aparece y le
pide andrés que piense un número le va a
mostrar el truco de números por lo cual
él también le pide a andrés que piense
un número vamos a llamarle x sumarle 5
le pide que le sume 5 le suma 5 y
multiplica el resultado y multiplica el
resultado por 3 multiplica el resultado
por 3 andrés dice que no importa la
manera como da el truco siempre obtiene
la misma respuesta cuál es el número de
andrés sin importar si primero
multiplica el número por 5 y luego le
resta 3 o primero le suma al número 5 y
luego lo multiplica por 3 siempre
obtiene el mismo número y eso significa
que estos dos son iguales obtiene la
misma respuesta significa que estos dos
números son iguales resolvamos entonces
esta ecuación tenemos que 5x menos 3 es
igual a 3 x más 5 esa es nuestra
ecuación como primer paso voy a
distribuir este 3 entonces esto es igual
a 3 por x + 3 por 5 15 no te olvides que
hay que multiplicar todos los términos
dentro del paréntesis por el 3
es 15 muy bien y del lado izquierdo por
supuesto es 5 x menos 3 y ahora creo que
ya sabes cómo me gusta operar
voy a llevar todos los términos en x a
un solo lado los voy a llevar al lado
izquierdo para eso voy a restar menos 3
x a ambos lados de la ecuación restamos
menos 3 x del lado izquierdo y restamos
menos 3 x del lado derecho del lado
izquierdo que tenemos tenemos 5 x menos
3 x es 2 x menos 3 del lado derecho 3 x
3 x se cancelan y sólo nos queda 15 esto
es igual a 15 ahora voy a pasar todos
los coeficientes al lado derecho voy a
cancelar este menos 3 para lo cual voy a
sumar 3 a ambos lados de la ecuación
sumo tres del lado izquierdo y sumó 3
del lado derecho que nos da ahora del
lado izquierdo nos queda 2 x 3 y 3 se
cancelan y del lado derecho va a ser 15
318 despejamos x dividiendo entre 2
ambos lados 2 entre 2 es igual a 1 así
es que x es igual a 10 y 82 x es igual a
9 en ambos casos
andrés
estaba pensando en el número 9 veamos si
esto funciona para el método de ambos el
de tamara y el de manuel si tengo cinco
por hagamos este 9 5 por 9 5 por 9 45
menos 345 menos 3 642 ese según el
método de tamara ahora según el método
manuel si tengo 9 + 5 es 14 así es que
esto es 3 por 14 y 3 por 14 estrés por
10 30 3 por 4 12 esto es igual 42 así es
que andrés tenía razón eligió al asad
del número 9 y sin importar el método
que siguió obtuvo el mismo número 42